[Music]
so we still have major unanswered
questions about why mass shooter Stephen
paddock carried out such a horrific and
evil act now during a news conference
earlier today the Clark County Sheriff's
Department said it still does not have a
motive we're waiting what's this to date
we have run down well more than a
thousand leads in this investigation
well some of it has helped create a
better profile into the madness of this
suspect we do not still have a clear
motive or reason why we're very
confident that he did not there was not
another shooter in that room what I
cannot confirm to you today and what we
continue to investigate is whether
anybody else may have known about this
incident before he carried it out now
senior law enforcement officials they're
telling NBC News that a cell phone
charger was found in the guns gun men's
room but it doesn't match any of
paddocks mobile phones and they're also
reporting that records show that during
a time when paddocks car left the hotel
parking garage one of his key cards was
used to enter his hotel room interesting
nuggets now the Clark County Sheriff's
Department did however say they were not
aware of that information there's also a
report tonight from CNN that the gunman
traveled overseas on over 20 cruises and
earlier today the Sheriff's Department
knocked down speculation that paddock
had been radicalized let's watch this we
have looked at everything literally to
include the suspects personal life any
political affiliation his social
behaviors economic situation and any
particular potential radicalization that
so many have claimed we're also aware of
course that Isis has repeatedly claimed
responsibility which today I can tell
you that we have no known Nexus to also
according to the AP Steven panic bought
1,000 rounds of what is known as tracer
ammunition that was a week before
carrying out this mass shooting now
those rounds were found in paddocks room
but authorities have yet to determine if
he used them during this attack and the
report also says that the police found a
a man at the crime scene with the name
of the Arizona man who allegedly sold
paddock those tracer rounds also the New
York Times reporting the paddock
he called Mandalay Bay security twice
the night before the shooting rampage he
was complaining about loud music coming
from the floor below him and law
enforcement has found an SUV belonging
to paddock that they were searching for
now the motive for this terrible tragedy
still remains a mystery and also tonight
in the face of the pure evil that we saw
in Las Vegas America this country is
learning some very valuable lessons
about coming together and unify however
despite the tragedy and despite the fact
that people are still in the hospital
they're fighting for their lives
well predictably there are people on the
Left Democrats celebrities liberals in
the mainstream media they continue to
politicize this tragedy beyond shameful
now because this is not what America is
all about
those people should know better but they
continue to politicize what happened
anyway every day and tonight I want to
focus on what America should be doing
now to help and support the great people
in Vegas now earlier in the week we
showed you this incredibly powerful
moment this was just one hour before the
shooting started in Las Vegas see that
Big & Rich on the stage crowd is singing
in unison god bless america
they're holding up their cell phones
together now those people they let out
Republicans there they're not democrats
liberal or conservatives they're they're
Americans they're singing god Bless
America and they're singing it in unison
and it didn't matter to the shooter who
they voted for he wasn't asking for ID
cards he wanted dead Americans he wanted
to shatter lives and instead of dividing
the country like the left is doing and
has been doing all week isn't it time
for the rest of the country to follow
the example that was set one hour before
this shooting by the people in that very
crowd and doesn't that start by
respecting our country our flag our
military those people that fought bled
and died under that flag for this
country for our freedoms to go to
concerts and by the way even after this
terrible tragedy on Sunday night two
players on the Kansas City Chiefs they
still refuse
to stand for the national anthem in
Monday Night Football
now the stadium did honor the Vegas
victims with a moment of silence but
those players still didn't rise for the
star-spangled banner I think it's a huge
mistake if they really wanted to make a
statement they should have come together
let the 58 Americans who were killed and
their families and the nearly 500 plus
injured let them know that their country
fully supports them and last night
during Thursday Night Football
all players finally stood for the anthem
we're gonna see what happens this
football Sunday but for the players
those of you that still refuse to stand
maybe you should look at this video of
Thomas Gunderson he was on this program
last night we went to see him in the
hospital after he stood to greet
President Trump and the first lady even
after being shot in the leg Gunderson
later wrote this very powerful message
on his Facebook page quote I will never
lie down when the president of this
great country comes to shake my hand
there may be plenty of issues in the
country but I will always respect my
country my president and my flag shot in
the leg or not I will stand to show my
president the respect he deserves
doesn't sound like he will be turning
down an invitation to the White House
but it's an example every American
should follow no not a perfect country
but you know what was still all
Americans and Thomas Gunderson he wasn't
playing politics he was focused on
healing and unity and those that
continue to divide this country you
should listen to the stories of just
some of the heroes from the Vegas
shooting just take a look at this and
pay really close attention because it
shows America's greatness America's
goodness take a look my buddy that was
standing right next to me said I'm here
then we knew is real most people started
scattering and they climbed the fence
but I had to stay with my buddies there
was Lhasa you know awesome military
ex-military people that were changed so
we got them compressed and that's you
know kept true christian on his chest
everyone who i thought you know is
passed on they happen to hard club my
clothing covering their eyes come on
Carter their body everyone who I saw
breathing
I hope man that went back inside and
images something that we do was trying
to be a hero I was just
I want to make sure that that wasn't a
pain right there was it a gentleman that
was shot and he said can you help me and
so I put him in my car and I had like
six people in my car people which shoes
running away another powerful lesson we
learned this week is how brave men and
women of law enforcement first
responders firemen policemen all of them
really are and the dangers they put
themselves in to keep all of us safe
take a look at this body cam video of
Las Vegas police officers they run
towards danger just like the police the
first responders the firemen on 9/11
2001 they run into danger as others try
and run away from danger take a look you
know you would think after seeing that
that the NFL players they really gonna
take a knee in protest the police this
weekend you know if NFL players if they
will show support for Colin Kaepernick
really the former 49ers quarterback who
started these protests by the way to
those players that they still stand by
Kaepernick even after you supported
groups like black lives matters that
have said what do we want dead cops when
do we want them now pigs in a blanket
fry them like bacon members of that
group said that I also wonder if those
players still have Kaepernick's back
after he wore remember these socks
depicting police officers as pigs and
Kaepernick also supported let's see a
murdering thug dictator named Fidel
Castro maybe one of the lessons from
this week is that we forgot what
happened on 9/11 we forgot the 9/11 cops
firefighters first responders those that
went up those stairs to save lives
running directly into danger to help
their fellow human beings out maybe this
week will teach us that we should stop
rushing to judgment on big high-profile
cases you may remember like President
Obama did so many times all the
Cambridge police acted stupid
Lior and the Michael Brown case in in
Ferguson Missouri hands up don't shoot
he got shot in the back none of it was
true
or Freddie gray in Baltimore maybe
police maybe we got to remember that
this this incident this week in 911
don't they deserve the presumption of
innocence next time and finally and most
importantly maybe the lesson from Vegas
in this tragedy will be that this
country needs to come together and it
starts this Sunday at the NFL and
stadiums all across the country by the
way Roger Goodell are you watching
because it's in your rule book are you
going to enforce your rules here with
reaction